hello and welcome to google developers
live my name is Arun Nagarajan and I'm
with the google apps developer relations
team we have a special GDL today we have
letter feet who is a great partner of
ours that's joined in here in the studio
and they're going to talk about the
great google docs add-on that they've
built and will actually take a look at
the ad on itself but more importantly
have a good conversation about how they
built it some of the challenges and
opportunities that they have faced so
before we dive into all the details
let's actually let them introduce
themselves yeah I'm Chris I'm Chris hon
and I'm the co-founder and CEO of Larry
feed hi I'm Catholic I'm the co-founder
and CTO of later feed that's great and
for the folks that are not familiar with
this letter feed deal what's the product
about whether uh put her what are you
doing holding uh letter P makes
collaboration tools for work I were
really excited to talk today about
letter feed sidebar which is a google ad
on and it's a single place for you to
see and discuss changes to your document
that's great and uh who's a typical user
of leather feed our typical users are
people who really depend on google apps
to run their business they're really
heavy users of Google Docs and sheets
they using a very collaborative way it's
oftentimes a lot of people editing and
viewing and uh and just making changes
to these Google Docs sheets that's great
so actually what do we take a look at
the ad on itself I think that the other
set the stage really well for some of
the other conversation sure sounds great
let's take a look at you in the computer
great so we can switch their demo so
letter fee the end is a single place for
you to see and discuss changes to your
documents and so it lives right
alongside your document so that in a
single glance you can quickly see and
see what people have been changing and
editing including who who's been
changing them and win so editions are
shown in green and deletions are shown
in red and it's also a great place just
have any sort of document related
conversation so if I'm making a few
edits here and say hey does does this
look okay so you'll be able to quickly
see and discuss any changes and any
message that he send will appear right
alongside the sidebar for all
documentary people to see of course not
everyone is editing an exact same time
so we actually will send out email if
they're offline so actually detect
presence and send an email if it's
applicable so in this case we're going
to switch over to our other user here
who got an email and he's able to
actually reply say hey I'll check it out
in a sec and hit Send and this message
will actually get posted back to the
sidebar we wanted to make the email
experience really great because editing
in a team's almost always an
asynchronous experience so we're going
to actually go into the document now is
Karthik you can see that his message is
actually posted on the left-hand side on
the beard also happened yeah the update
also happened so now you're showing the
the app the add-on for two different
users hamilton's in the same screen so
on the left is Chris on the right is
Karthik so cardiac is going to is able
to see that his message has already been
seen so we actually show you anytime
someone has actually read your message
or your change so you'll never have to
wonder if someone's actually read your
document that's great and a car takes
can I post a message which includes a
link uh-huh and any link is highlighted
and actually intelligently previewed
whether it's an article a link to a
Google Drive file or this case a photo
some really cute cats and so we want to
provide a really rich experience so
you'd have those discussions you need to
put together your document so we've also
enabled the ability to just copy and
paste by dragging dropping content from
the sidebar so any text or or photos
that you're discussing can automatically
be be added immediately that's great
yeah I've been myself using it a little
bit here and there and I kind of enjoyed
the the constant history that attracts
and in a nice way that it provides the
summary of the changes not just the
snapshots right so I think that's a
really cool thing that you guys offering
to tell me a little bit about some of
the technical details behind the ad on
what some of the salient points of the
integrations were and
if you can give some back or not sure
sure so I think fundamentally likely
defeat is like a multi-client service
right like we started off as you know a
standalone website and you know since
then we of course introduced the sidebar
and so you know as a result of you know
building this multi client service right
like we really tried our best to
seamlessly blend the best of you know
having Apps Script plus having our own
service that is you know really doing
the diffs as a result we are using both
Apps Script API is as well as you know
the oauth2 API is seamlessly and you
know to the user it's completely
transparent think the biggest thing to
keep in mind is that when you are trying
to actually build an add-on test early
and test often with any libraries that
you want to use in the caja sandbox and
so that way right like you can like
pretty early on figure out like what is
going to work for you right and that
will also make a software development
lot more predictable that's great what
are some of the interesting metrics that
you'll be tracking was this launches
we're going to be looking really closely
a retention engagement something
retention side we're going to looking at
day one retention for new users to make
sure they stick around and weekly return
rates for current users on the gateman
side will be looking a lot at frequency
of use per day are they getting a lot of
use on it on multiple documents and also
sense I'd metrics let's take a quick
look at the the sort of multi-client
design that you talked about that's on
the computer here and well of course you
kind of talk to some other key things
you've done here sure with that I mean
this is this is great I really enjoyed
using the add-on I urge you all to go
try it on it'll be on the add-ons
marketplace and good luck with the
launch and thank you very much for being
here in the studio with us introducing
the add-on thanks for having us thanks